[Music] Don't
tell me, it's not
true. Seriously, these guys look at Barrow not making a pass, and then they use a
combo attack, and they switch, and I'm
Kunigami. I'm at a
complete numerical disadvantage, and I have no choice but to stop him at the final line. He
hits me with a triple.  Either that
or Kuni Ga Mie's pasta.
Wait until the last minute and you can respond to either.
Keep your distance and read the timing of Leo's choice. It's
Kunigami. The opponent is Leo who is a
force to be reckoned with. As expected, his speed
slows down at the moment of the trap.
Red Panther catches up to him.  I'm happy for just a moment
[Music] It's
my shadow.
Seriously? It's the
first time we've matched up, but it's
disgustingly fast and it's annoying. Our
formation was
completely destroyed.
Three people with the speed of a country understood each other's weapons.
It's a proof test to surpass the geniuses of Barrow and Nagi by drawing out each other's abilities
[Music]